democrats and now even some republicans
in congress say president trump is
responsible for the violent and deadly
attack on the u.s capitol last week
they want the president out of office
even before the inauguration of
president-elect joe biden
alexander limon is live with us this
morning from washington d.c with the
latest on what's going on on capitol
hill
alex good morning and democratic leaders
say they will move forward with their
first attempt
to remove president trump from office
just a little later this morning
and now even republican senators pat
toomey and lisa murkowski say president
trump simply needs to resign
speaker of the house nancy pelosi says
democrats will try to pass a resolution
to pressure
vice president mike pence to invoke the
25th amendment
and tried to remove president trump from
office i believe
donald trump is a threat every single
day when he is at 1600 pennsylvania
if the vice president does not respond
in 24 hours
democrats say they'll seek to impeach
president trump
senator ron wyden of oregon says
president trump incited the mobs
that invaded the u.s capitol this is
part
of making it clear that
the country understands the enormity of
the damage that was done by
domestic terrorists republican senator
roy blunt
says impeaching the president again
would only divide the country further
speaker knows this is not going to
happen senator schumer knows this isn't
going to happen
you don't have the time for it to happen
even if there was a reason
democratic congressman james clyburn
says the house could vote to impeach the
president this week
and then wait on sending the articles to
the senate for a trial
let's give president elect biden
the 100 days he needs to get his agenda
off
and running so i think the president did
commit impeachable offenses
there's little doubt in my mind about
that i'm also not at all clear
that it's constitutionally permissible
to impeach someone after they have left
office
now if a senate impeachment trial does
happen after president trump has already
left the white house it could
potentially stop him
from running for office again in the
future if he is convicted in that trial
live in washington alexandra limon
alexander thank you very much very
fast-moving developments there we'll
keep an eye on things appreciate it